carlos has pitched very well in inner
league play in his career ten and four
to 263 era
he's coming off a start against uh
cincinnati where he went six innings and
did not allow a run
swung on him as
high heat one down here to start the
game for the cubbies tonight he's making
his first start
uh he is two and one
on the season he's fit farewell 354
earned run average he always pitches
better at home than he does on a road
that balls up the alley in right center
field and he will vote for second base
and hat misplays it he's around second
and he'll hold right there
it'll be a one out double for jose
ramirez look how squeaked through and he
almost hit last diaz who's running out
of the way
that is the cubs first hit
like he was being chased by a squirrel
there in the middle of the diamond
chops it between third and short and it
goes by bodhi
in the left field he got a glove on it
and on the deflection baez had no chance
anthony rizzo leads off as that ball is
smacked into the right field corner gone
a home run for rizzo
an absolute one iron
it's one to nothing
[Applause]
well there's no consistency and it's not
helping
that carrasco has been inconsistent
himself and out comes carl willis
carl willis
trying to get carlos carrasco back on
track
you can tell cookie is unnerved usually
he doesn't say anything but you know i
think he's just frustrated
well he's the only one that can help
himself out here
i mean he's got to dig down deep deep
and make him swing the bats
swung and missed the ball gets away and
the runners will advance so he gets the
strikeout his fifth
but the wild pitch
puts two in scoring position though
strong out of this he chased it in the
dirt and carrasco has struck out back to
back hitters
and now a chance to get himself out of
it
high fly ball to left
mike freeman
[Applause]
makes the catch
cookie survives two walks two strikeouts
cub strand affair
you can tell with the salt and pepper
beard that he's got going
here comes the 2-2 rizzo swings and
lines one into right field for a base
hit so a lead off single for the cubs to
begin the fifth inning and now the heart
of the lineup coming up with baez
contreras and hapdoo up the 3-2 of the
runner going is hit in the air
shallow right top play it's gonna drop
down
and rizzo to third
and the cubs have it cooking again here
in the fifth
so now the bases are loaded with one
away it'll bring up jason hayward a
lefty on lefty matchup the pitch by
perez de hayward he swings and hits one
high in the air to right playable for
the right fielder naquin it'll bring
home a run he makes the catch short of
the track rizzo tags he's coming home
here comes the throw the slide safe as
the ball catch by the catcher and the
runners advance
to second and third so the cubs score
their second run of the game on the
sacrifice fly by hayward cubs two
indians nothing here in the fifth round
he's ready so is the lefty perez here
comes the pitch bodhi swings line drag
base hit into right field one run is in
his bias scores half racing home he will
score and bodhi is caught in a rundown
between first and second and he's tagged
out but not before the cubs plate two
more on the two-run single by david body
they lead four to nothing now
here in the fifth inning
here's the 1-1 breaking ball swung
online shallow left center and that
falls in for a base hit for tyler naquin
so naquin goes the other way left center
finds the hole
gets his third hit of the year and the
indians have something brewing in the
fifth on back to back singles indians
have something rolling they need a base
hit here to get something on the board
jose ramirez one for two with a double
popped to
shallow left center
bryant makes the grab tagging
[Applause]
get on the board
two down ramirez gets his team leading
13th run batted in on the year
bryant
high and deep left center
gone a home run
five to one brian took matters into his
own hands and jumped all over that 0-1
offering
from simber for his second home run of
the year 3-2 again
lined into center field to base it
hernandez will score ramirez on his way
to third he'll go in there safely
they're at the corners another run home
as lindor delivers with his 10th running
bat at end of the year and it's a 5-2
ball game jason kittmas the batter with
two on one out i've seen some people's
that ball is hit down the left field
line and it is a fair ball
[Applause]
and it goes out of play so it'll be a
run-scoring double it's six to two
caratini to third
jason kipnis
with another extra base hit
comes lead by four runs here in the
ninth inning with two outs in a man at
first hayward lines one toward right
base set it's going to go all the way to
the wall in the corner racing toward
third as hap rounding third heading home
here comes the relay the throw to the
plate the slide by half not in time rbi
double jason hayward cubs lead 7-2
[Applause]